bruselas ha reaccionado rápidamente a
londres el vicepresidente de la comisión
europea maros sefcovic ha advertido al
gobierno británico que el acuerdo sobre
el protocolo de irlanda del norte no se
renegocia que eso no es una opción
porque ha recordado que tanto la unión
europea como el gobierno británico
negociaron votaron y luego ratificaron
este protocolo de irlanda del norte que
permite que no haya una frontera física
entre la república de irlanda y la
región de irlanda del norte la comisión
europea ha asegurado que analizará
seriamente la propuesta de londres pero
que se reserva todas las medidas legales
a su alcance porque recuerda que esta
medida es totalmente unilateral y que
contraviene el derecho internacional y
cuáles podrían ser estas medidas legales
para empezar vuelve a reactivar la vía
judicial envuelve a reactivar un
procedimiento de infracción que abrió el
año pasado bruselas pero que asegura en
un espíritu de buena fe y de negociación
con londres decidió paralizar una buena
fe que según bruselas a londres no ha
seguido por el mismo camino además
también se guarda la posibilidad de
impedir que algunas empresas pueden
empresas británicas de irlanda del norte
no puedan tener acceso al mercado único
aún así todo esto que es lo que puede
implicar pues que londres podría en
última instancia acabar en el tribunal
de justicia de la unión europea a un
tribunal de londres asegura que ahora
mismo no va a reconocer aún así bruselas
dice que mantiene la puerta abierta que
está dispuesta a negociar y a mantener
flexibilidad es a flexibilizar el
acuerdo de protocolo de irlanda del
norte para encontrar una solución por el
bien de las dos partes y también por el
bien de la población de irlanda del
norte aún así si las tensiones se
mantienen si sigue así la tensión podría
haber una guerra comercial en que la
unión europea y también reino unido-
pueden aplicar aranceles lo que
complicaría aún más la situación
económica en un momento de gran
incertidumbre a causa de la inflación en
todo el mundo